let the gang banger watch what the [ __ ]
did I just watch on games of cons and I
should have knew that this ship was
going to piss me off three four five
this [ __ ] man
I know you love the [ __ ] did not kill
him you [ __ ] bags of dicks oh
[ __ ] Holly now oh [ __ ] you ollie
we're good Ollie you will pray just go
to start I'm so over crying over this
curse all y'all y'all just killed Daryl
Rick Grimes on the dock they're walking
there why are you doing this [ __ ]
Madison you [ __ ] on games of
Thrones you writers if y'all don't find
a way to get some of that dragon blood
of something over there dragon [ __ ]
back and bring him the [ __ ] back I will
never look against the Thrones again at
HBO y'all can just shoot my drops cuz
your fucked-up True Blood and now you're
[ __ ] up games of Thrones and other
[ __ ] to tell me that it's
something like the book I don't give a
[ __ ] even half the day first we had the
bloody ass [ __ ] wet and [ __ ]
shaming and de [ __ ] getting kids to
dare [ __ ] some [ __ ] games of
Thrones
I can't y'all to walk me out honey you
got a [ __ ] ready to are on drugs which
I never would but you my [ __ ]
drive [ __ ] and closer some good bubbles
with George are larger things I'm sorry